[Music]
buddies
yes
oh that's really what it's all about
ironically
it's all about the body as you know with
each spark of infinity is
one of these costumes
um wow then why would i ever judge
another
jesus that just blew that one right at
the gate
yep uh why judge myself
yeah it's very innocent i guess why
commit malevolence
against myself that's the bigger
question
right yeah
yeah yeah for myself
yeah yeah the logic is flawed and
it's people are going to be waking up to
that pretty rapidly
karma karma can be um a good
pristine mirror um
yeah you know yeah and it's like who
and then it's like who am i right to
blame
who am i to judge someone's dance with
her
at the same time unless i'd like to
create funny little karma glitches for
myself
and as i say this i i i'm calling
the ignorant part of me out that still
experiences it because it's so innocent
and so
and so somehow not judging the self for
judging the self
at the same time there's two core parts
though
what we're talking about right now that
i want to hit the tennis ball back on
one of them is 2500 years ago
top delphic maxim written on
the temple of apollo adelphi two words
know thyself
why why did they pick know thyself
well because as we talk about how can
you commit
malevolence when you know your true
nature why
would you ever take
this and begin hitting
your yeah yeah yourself stop getting
yourself
yeah it's exactly
you're hitting yourself my cousin said
that to me when i was a kid
that would take my hands and hit me with
them and they'd say why are you hitting
yourself
it was really frustrating because i
wasn't trying to
yeah i didn't know
i didn't realize that they were me just
revealing to me a
microcosmic fractal of what i'm doing on
a universal level
until this moment so now i'm grateful
for them for their teachings
even though i wish they would have done
it in a nicer way
so that's their own karma to deal with
making their little cousin
hit himself but at the same time
it's very innocent and who's to say that
that was
anyway i'm going off on a thing
another way to ano another way to phrase
it
is to say that
getting out of your own way
is in itself
both an
illusion and yet it is also the
psychology the conditioning the ego
the not knowing yourself the ignorance
being behind the veilless veil and not
knowing that
true nature and so getting out of your
own way means deconditioning
yourself from your psychology from the
ego
from the behavioral patterns of
self-dealing service to self dynamics
that when you don't know your true
nature that those are
those cores that light up and then the
other part that i just want to mention
quick is that
you said the dance
each one of us has our own unique dance
with the infinite that we're going
through and
could it possibly be that every single
one of those dances is just
already ineffable perfection and just
zip and
night nice type thing yeah
it could be i mean there's nothing
there's nothing there that's the thing
is like oh yeah
it's all words let's call it that thing
cool let's call it any word other than
ineffable perfection
let's play that game and see what
happens
and then when you realize that words are
just words
then it's like oh what's the word for
the thing when we're not trying to like
pretend we're not trying to pretend it's
like oh let's dress that thing up in a
let's call that one and that thing let's
call that one of that thing
there comes a time where it's like um
oh what happens when we stop trying to
play the game of like
calling things and see what things are
without words
you know i think as a collective it's
kind of like the scientific the western
mind is
is gonna have to come to a place of like
okay cool we tried that game
the word and then it's like a word that
helps point me back to what's
beneath my my my human
the toys the human toys of the words
when i'm not playing those games is like
oh inevitable perfection
works to direct me to the fact that yes
any word that i call that and then call
that
i create automatically a gap of
a gap of perceived separation in between
but really there is no in between
and you know i could call it really a
lot of words but ineffable perfection
works and it's also important i think to
explain why we call it that because some
people have a hard time
with that word because they're like
things are not perfect
yeah because there's war and poverty and
stuff like that
yeah and there's there's a couple
components here
so first is is that
it's mission critical to understand that
the analysis of
form infinity as science does is
absolutely
amazing and incredible and really
mission critical for planetary
flourishing
and it's what enables us to have what we
have right now
in what we're doing and also at the same
time
it's completely
not being synthesized at all with
spirituality
to the extent at which when it does get
synthesized to spirituality at a deeper
level
it will understand the fundamental
salience the poignancy the very
paramountness
itself of awareness
of consciousness and then then
it will be able to become and infinity
awareness and infinity and as it does
that
then science and spirituality
synthesized will be able to ascend
together
in a more harmonic way which right now
is
already incredibly happening but is
still
there's too much dissonance that's still
creeping around
people not knowing themselves as
impersonal shared awareness or even
knowing that they share the same [ __ ]
source
and thinking that they're just uh yeah a
finite like
oh yeah we hear the same earth let's
start there
oh yeah mm-hmm yeah so it's very simple
also
when it goes back to oh yeah where did
we all come from
yeah yeah it has to it has to be the
question has to be
ask the deeper questions that's how you
get to
the realization you don't get to the
realization
via being stuck in
the nine-to-five economic machinery
grind and then
randomly out of nowhere being dropped
the golden nugget of realization
that it takes this seeking impulse which
is literally your lifeline to the
creator
it which you already are you're seeking
impulse is what is
the in a sense the absolute gps callback
as
ventino sorrow has been saying and it is
literally
your most sacred most divine aspect
which is
the the self inquiry the atma vichra the
very process of asking yourself
what is i what am i what is my true
nature and then getting yourself to
these answers and what you said a moment
ago around ineffable perfection is
really important because
you have to understand it's ineffable
perfection perfection
and it's perfecting you will never be
able to get away from that second part
of perfecting
you can't just say it is perfect being
can't exactly it's always simultaneity
it's perfect being and it's perfect
perfecting
it's become that's why heraclitus said
two thousand five hundred years ago
ponte rey everything flows while
parmenidus said
all movement is an illusion and so you
bring the two together
and you recognize that war and poverty
are
yes just like the taijitsu you have the
monism
and you have the dualistic yin yang in
it so war and poverty
are the creation of ourselves in order
for us to have contrast
in order for us to perfect away from war
and poverty exactly
exactly
yeah ironically the more we accept
what feels the most shitty as ineffable
perfection
the more it blossoms right
no mud no lotus very classic carl jung
carlos
one of my favorite i love this one i
throw it around everywhere everyone
should know it
the deeper a tree cannot branch into
heaven
lest its roots reach into hell
only to that degree right and so really
it's just like
oh yeah a breaking news announcement
this is a psa for the planet earth
collective
um it's all a paradox so like
the thing of like this verse that you're
right it's like i can't it's like oh
yeah that one
so this has been an experiment of like
oh what does that look like to pretend
to like try to make this versus that and
it's like oh yeah
poverty war all that cool how do we
remember
it's all paradoxically together
part of an ineffable perfection oh it
already is that
cool so then
that keeps doing what it's doing and
already and it's just more efficient so
it's like really like
if we all understood how efficient the
process of global
civilization healing uh
you know whatever we're trying to do
that our heart
our heart is like hey that hurts when i
see that person hurt
it's like oh what does that really mean
oh we're one
okay cool that's why i love this person
right
so then we can get caught up in our
fight for the world
but then make a bad guy out to be the
thing that we have to conquer
that could be like that's part of the
inevitable perfection right that's
that's you know somehow that's doing
whatever it's doing
and it's also like hey i have a
theory that i've experienced miracles
through
applying which is that the more that we
realize
the underlying unity that has been
forgotten in the creation
of the perception of separation manifest
as
human suffering the way to really
heal that is to come to terms with
the wholeness there beyond our mental
ideas of it
right uplift the mental ideas within us
self-responsibility
we cannot point the fingers outside
right self-responsibility so we heal
that
we heal that projection of the
perception of separation through taking
self-responsibility
to no longer make the world something
bad that way we can approach
the world as what it truly is as
as ourselves right all coming as
all seeds coming from the same father
mother
universe sun earth beyond even
soros and then like okay cool and then
we become
um anyway you can
i made this why would i
ever be a victim to what i made
it's a stupid limiting belief
that is being eradicated from
civilization because we recognize that
we designed our own [ __ ] escape rooms
we designed our own [ __ ] labyrinths
you know and so that's where
like you said there's the
self-responsibility portion of the
awakening
i'm the [ __ ] designer of my own
labyrinth
and so it's a beautiful process for me
to go through
the labyrinth-less labyrinth and
there's also like you said the holism
heals realizing the undercurrent of
unity also
becoming aware that creation
is in fact the most efficient
vehicle for intelligent infinity
to play with planets and civilizations
and people in costumes and the dynamics
that happened between them
it's the 101 the 101
it's the 101 it's like oh creation works
the best
perfect keep creating knowing that you
are creation
that's how it works it creates
its creation so want to align with it
want to make it you know want to honor
the the creation
um yeah
quit pretending that you're not creation
yeah oh just
miss our godzilla has this great quote
he says that you are
the source of infinite possibility
yeah and then there's so much compassion
like
at the same time for where it's not
it doesn't feel like we're the creator
all right for the for the for the part
of our self that
we may perceive you know the human
collective
that we may perceive to be
not in the realization of their true
nature
there's such ineffable perfection
and it's like
so then because the whole thing is
really love and relentless compassion
the likes of which hardly any humans
have tasted
so we're bringing through a very
masculine approach which i love
it's because it's the men the mind is
necessary we have to learn
what the [ __ ] our mind is doing
we have to learn what what our mind is
doing
and then we and so the real thing is
just to empty it out
empty the mind of like learn to to trust
that there is a source
for our experience and
any place where we are identified or
we're experiencing things that
feel out of alignment right there might
be some thought we picked up along the
way
that has kind of lodged itself in our
brain
and so we learned to do the work of like
the very simple work of like
even here even with all these thoughts
even with all these feelings i'm still
ineffable perfection
which kind of relaxes all these beliefs
that believe they were anything else
right and then the brain kind of becomes
empty clear which humanity is terrified
of that's what
the ego fears the most right because it
feels like existential death
right the the infamous death of the ego
but it's only relevant you know what the
the
it's also like it's part of the picture
what it does
in my experience is it creates a open
transparent channel
for more energy to be
able to be experienced brought through
the physical vessel more
more more energy to be felt right
there's also some like
feeling the immensity of human suffering
involved while having
enough clarity to not pretend that it's
not there to pretend that we can resist
it
right enough clarity to not pretend we
can resist the immensity
of what we're actually all sitting here
together in
and then in that is like a radical
compassion
that um
that yeah is just here to love in a very
simple way
at the same time love everything
love everything and and be the like let
right i did not come here to teach you i
came here to love you
love will teach you so there's something
very humbling about the way that the
feminine
dimension manifests as this earth and as
the body and as the human family
and as this mud
that demands from the man's for me she
humbles me
she brings me to my knees and i say i'm
so sorry
how could i ever be so arrogant
how deeply i love you yeah
yeah it's it's the full
realization of that undercurrent of
unity
at the experiential degree of prana
of the very life force itself
which
that is that we have
and those are the two being merged
together that's when science and
spirituality also get the chance to
really be able to have incredible
sex is yeah yeah is at your feeling
because because really they 69
already but
like the shirt but 69 gets most intense
with signs of spirituality when they
recognize that what is
explained by prana the very
20 000 of these breaths per day as
life force is the very incredible
analysis of form infinity that we've
made on the planet with science where we
say that those 20
000 breaths per day literally come
from the photosynthesis of phytoplankton
and trees
and so the level of interdependence is
you cannot exist here
without the insane
interdependence on this beautiful
feminine mother earth energy that
fractaled you
out as a secretion for you
to be able to know and experience
your own creation it's [ __ ] perfect
she's so beautiful and sexy and juicy
yes
yeah we've been in a drought
psychically a psychological drought
due to our disconnection with her like
she is
it oh nature is god
oh everything's a miracle
oh wow it's so it's so beautiful oh wow
there's so much abundance here
[Music]
and even then when we when our perceived
what we think we need we've been taught
by the culture that put us in the box
put us behind the screen that put us in
the classroom that put us in the
perceived community perceived government
system
etc when we kind of
realized that all those things that we
have been sold to believe
um would be really good and fulfilling
to like
try to get when we realized that like
[ __ ]
that's not working
then we grieve that i find there's like
there's like confusion and then there's
like the mind's like trying to hold on
to something
right so a lot of people right now on
earth
mind is confusing what do i hold on to
what side do i defend what side do i go
against
right you know
what what do i do and uh because they
don't know it's their own creation
right yeah and then and then i find that
it's like yeah so there's a sense of
lack that we're fundamentally
uh there's a fundamental assumption of
lack of i mean
things serious yeah and then when
nothing's there and you grieve it all
and you like
and it's like [ __ ] what do i do i have
nothing like
whatever happens whether you get
crucified or [ __ ] you lose your
girlfriend that you were in love with or
you know you realize that the drug
addiction isn't good for you
whatever it is it's like or even just a
very simple
um who the [ __ ] am i like
okay i know who my parents are kind of
like i know
what people around me that i grew up
with are doing who the [ __ ] am i
and something happens where you like
[ __ ] that's actually the greatest gift
where we realize the most abundance
through the gateway of loss perceived
loss
and then in those moments it's like what
really matters
what really matters when the whole world
is
seemingly in a frenzy right when the
whole world is in
war and poverty and sick
and fighting itself and you know
whatever the thing is
what what is it really bringing us back
to what is really really really
actually important then what the [ __ ]
are we doing
what the [ __ ] are we doing what are we
looking for
and then it's like okay the mind it's
good
it's good the mind let the mind keep
whirling let it do its thing eventually
it exhausts itself
and then when there's nothing to hold
anymore because you realize thoughts are
not real things
and that all of life has been
ran by a filter of thoughts making
stories about reality
then you realize oh wait the earth is
[ __ ] abundantly gorgeous
here i am connected to her through my
breath and
it's so simple and i'm so abundant
because i am the infinite i am alive
and everything is here with me and
sometimes we have to be pushed to the
brink of ego freak out
in order to have that ego dissolve and
realize
oh that was never real
and it's uh the most beautifully
heartbreaking
complex deep dirty
and also uh simple and innocent and
playful
thing ever because it's all of it
and that's how it works around here
apparently
so the humor is essential too the
simplicity like oh yeah
and i love i love that you know what's
up with that
and i'm sure you've also been through
your shadows right through your through
your journey
so i'm curious could you share a bit
maybe
about one of those moments for you i
don't know if you've already shared on
this show
but
i i love how you bring up
suffering as that greatest gift the
drill sergeant of awakening itself is
this
gateway of perceived loss like you said
and
that is so fundamental
that we have this assumption of lack
and we have this mind toiling us around
feeling lack and feeling
like these thought clouds are so
essential
and that then we become liberated as we
become
more of the witness and we become less
absorbed
in the actual thought emotion
perception sensation patterns
it's incredible because as we sort of
take that back seat becoming aware of
awareness itself we also recognize that
our source is shared awareness is shared
that
this is but one of our creations and
that we have
an endless amount of exploration to
that we've been doing that we're going
to keep doing and that's the beauty
that's the beauty of
intelligent infinity endlessly
expressing itself
as the leela the divine play
and humor by the way the whole humor and
causeless joy thing
is something that although i could say
although i could say that a lot of my
sort of satori
the sort of micro satori was in the
middle of last year and then the
like macro satori was at the end of
last year and at the beginning of this
year so
although i could say that my like macro
level satori had happened
maybe even like a month or two ago
i still hadn't
really tapped into the just
pure causeless joy
and imperturbable peace and
just gigglefest
that and that's why the humor is so
essential and whatnot and
and so people people have been messaging
me the last like
you know month or two and they're just
like you know
what what's what's going on like okay
okay okay mr satori why are you so
[ __ ] serious
and and that was you know my response
and my response to them
was that you know i really only broke
through into the giggle fest
like a week ago
because because what would i what i did
because because when i did a week what i
did a year ago
if people only knew how much how much
debris that alleviates
people only knew how important it was
for our planet for us to laugh more
yeah and the the thing is is that
whenever people look at what
was the trajectory for me
and they come up with that understanding
of like why
why are you so serious well and you know
in 2020
i had to go 80 hours a week
non-stop hardcore on the seeking impulse
for me to pierce that bayless veil and
to recognize my true nature
and so a lot of my content around that
time
and even into kind of early 2021 is
like it has a fairly serious edge to it
um and and so
you know humor and you know causeless
joy
is your true nature
but in order for you to really
unlock the lockless
lock of that
the process
leverages seriousness in the form of
earnestness to know your true nature the
most
yeah so that would be my little answer
to that was that
i would say you know earnestness was my
biggest key and that's why you know
nisargatsuda also says earnestness is ki
sadhara meshwar as well
that there's basically an endless supply
in a sense of people that know their
true nature there's a lot of people and
there's a lot of
direct pointings but there are very
very few discipled
disciplined disciples and
that's that's the key so a disciplined
disciple was
yeah the key for me and that's how the
awareness is so important
that we're bringing in giving the option
hey here's the thing it's not really a
thing
it's actually the thing beneath all the
things
but you kind of need to make it all
about
the thing beneath the things to realize
that there was nothing
else ever to make it about
and we kind of have to yes so you just
so where did that earnestness come from
because that's
that's the that's the thing
and also simultaneously it's the
causeless joy and the [ __ ] it let's just
play on earth thing
at the same time and so
a lot of people are overly serious about
things that are not founded in reality
and also the way that the polarity of
that swings is they therefore
we love to you know we have an impulse
to just
play naturally in no thing land
in giggle fest but
it's all too serious to do that right
but the problem is we're not
serious about the actual thing we're
serious about the illusion of a thing
when you're really serious about the
actual thing then you're serious about
something that is completely not serious
at the same time
because the seriousness that we're
conditioned to think it's all about is
some time based construct
of something that we have to get to and
then we forget
what is already always here that which
is already always here
which is why they call it the leela or
the play
because when you're really present
um play is really the best word that
speaks to what is
what what is happening when there's no
agenda in the illusion of time
and yet simultaneously to play so we're
here to have fun
and enjoy the earth simultaneously we
can't enjoy it to the
maximum capacity unless we become
relentlessly earnest and real
all the way with all the places within
us
where we forget
how free we already are
and
yeah and then simultaneously in the play
the authentic joy right the causeless
joy
also comes through as some
authentic impulse to serve
how do we serve the people experiencing
war
and poverty because that is the most
blissful thing to do when you realize
that you're the whole universe
and how fun it is to co-create in love
with so much to love it's like oh we're
infinity how can we
remember and expand our consciousness
around all the places we've resisted
we've been taught to other and therefore
in that embrace of the whole we get to
expand
our infinity loveness even and realize
its inherent
already infinity loveness even more but
in that perceived
tension of contraction that experiential
tension of contraction
there gets to be a really epic
experience
this would be a good time to also
explain the little
banner that people see right now which
is buddha plus atlas
which is as we've been discussing
that what happens is
by learning your true nature what you do
is you undergo this
sort of nirvanic giggle fest
and there's so much energy there
just waiting yeah and then
and then inevitably you
also
as you ascend you also weave
your realizations terrestrially as atlas
in the sustainable development goals and
all these other types of things that
we've been we've been mentioning so yes
and that
and that's why they're ultimately one
buddha and atlas are
ultimately one and that
going you can't be buddha
without being atlas because
then how well do you actually know your
true nature
because you know if you knew truly
although all is illusion you would know
also that
the experience in the dream
can be accelerated by your will and
choice to
assist the other expressions of yourself
in the dream and then you can't go on
the atlas side
without realization because what happens
is even though you
think that you're
serving the sustainable development
goals you're doing it from
person consciousness and so
you can't actually serve
for bringing a billion people clean
water on the planet
if you don't actually know
that the other people are yourself
that you're in the employees and the
team are yourself
that the people you're serving are
yourself you you don't
you're you're gonna always have
something
where you feel like why don't i
why do i experience suffering why am i
doing something of the sustainable
development goals
but why am i still feeling like in my
relationship
with my significant other that i'm
feeling
anger arising well that's because you
don't know your true nature because you
haven't studied
yourself as the eternal impersonal sky
of awareness
watching the clouds appear and disappear
but that's
so that's what the core is really it's
always the synthesis
buddha atlas science spirituality monism
dualism
always always synthesis synthesis
simultaneity always
you know and that's the whole idea of
the holy trinity really
um but yeah this and so that's
yeah there's so much there right in
order to serve
as fully as possible we have to become
empty enough
to be vessels so simultaneously
the more the less it's about us right
the more we realize
how empty everything inherently is
which is something not only hard to
grasp but impossible to grasp
as long as we as soon as we get
comfortable with the discomfort
and begin to kind of build some
relationship
of knowingness with the unknown
kind of like okay i know i can't know
um there's there's like
there's simultaneously yeah so then it
animates the humanity
in service to the humanity it makes it
makes the full human be able to come
online
when the idea of the human is not there
the full human comes online which
happens to be
a whole a whole
super organism that we are all vessels
for
we're all vessels for this energy
but in order to efficiently efficiently
generate the most beneficial energy
for self we must do so for the
collective and vice versa
i really see the vessel as just a
channel for one energy
right that we're all constantly
symbiotically feeding
it's it's right the in the infinite 69
that's happening where we are breathing
in
the air we are breathing in the universe
we are breathing in life we're breathing
in god simultaneously we're doing that
it's breathing out into us
and then it's breathing us in but we are
actually that
air we are actually that life we
actually that energy
and this is actually a yeah a really
powerful meditation that catalyzed some
good things in my body
and i awoke energy within my as i was
meditating on uh i'll just share this
story i guess since
i'm in it this is okay so i'll share
about
a powerful experience one of the first
[Music]
sparks i was and just so people know
that when people undergo this process
know that you're listening to yourself
tell a story
just recognize that aspect to this
process that's happening right now
and really enjoy the nature of you
telling yourself
a story tune in pay attention
give love and respect it's you sharing a
story with yourself
so just for your references as you
do this process with those that are are
sharing
you're listening to yourself so please
i'm really pumped let's do this
thank you yes so it's a beautiful thing
to share a story it's a funny thing
but um as long as it's not victimization
right so don't create the space
for victimization stories create the
space for stories around
self-realization and the good
yeah yeah okay so the story started off
in this way where
i was a sophomore in high school i was
curious
about things so i asked
about kabbalah to my uncle he had
studied kabbalah
he taught me a kabbalistic meditation a
non-dual kabbalistic meditation
where you meditate upon the god within
as you breathe the god within you
excellent god without
so this
this character this was 15 years old
a sophomore in high school and
had a one of those grumpy fights with my
parents
and totally feeling like a victim they
were feeling like you know
i was my parents and my mom says
why don't you go in your room and calm
down and meditate
like you learned and i got quite
triggered by that
how dare you i'm very much enjoying
feeling that this is all unfair i will
not
meditate no especially not because you
asked but i did it
something within me was like oh
what if i got over myself and did that
that might be a good idea
so this character did that and
basically as i was going into my body
and feeling with consciousness
right going and feeling god on the
contemplation of god
on the contemplation that i am god
that what i am breathing in is me
and you trace that down you breathe it
in through your third eye
right all the way down the spine and you
fill up
the whole body with the love light of
the self just consciousness right
because consciousness is designed
actually to leak
out outside the blame gets put on side
put on the outside as soon as
consciousness turns inside there can be
a contemplation a remembrance
that this is all inside
that everything is actually inside right
all we have is our own consciousness
and but that must be experientially
realized that everything already
inherently is then doesn't
you don't have to really try to get to
the place
oh my god
so long story short
something as i was going down my body i
felt the tingle i felt the tingle of
light
going down my spine and i was like holy
[ __ ] this is magic
this is something is happening right the
science of consciousness was revealing
itself to me in a laboratory of my own
beingness and body
and something sparked and uh
yeah i almost left my body i got too
scared
everything flashing lights around me
began to leave my body
didn't know would be on the other side
so i used my thoughts
to bring myself back into the perception
that i exist as a separate being in this
body i used
the weight of my thoughts i thought and
i thought to bring myself back
because it i didn't trust the unknown i
didn't know actually
what would happen and usually it's good
things happen when that
happens and you get to realize and
experience more of
who you are beyond the perception of
what is being experienced within
the 3d vehicle that is currently being
actually physiologically
transformed to allow more energy through
right epigenetics are unlocking or going
through a metamorphosis
at this time into butterflies believe it
or not humanity
and that is something i'm very excited
about because it really is the whole
body
the the body is the universe when the
body when consciousness wakes up
in the body when the cells begin to
wake up no longer be contracted
right consciousness is brought inward we
find that the body contains infinity
through it we find it's a magical like
thing through which
it's a holographic projector
device that um
miracles are worked through when one is
abiding
as the [ __ ] relentless knowing of who
the
[ __ ] they are as christ consciousness
and it's also a very tender thing to
explore what the body needs
so there's this aspect of the solar
solar consciousness
like oh i'm actually infinite energy
i'm actually the sun i'm actually i'm
light
right i'm pure light
there's like this fire a [ __ ]
purification
and transmutation that lights up the
kundalini whatever you want to call it
that burns away what's not true that can
withhold anything
and only burns what we are not anything
this life just scorches us
and it's the purifying fire right
and then there's also the medicine of
the water
and uh and it's really beautiful that
there's all these self-care movements
happening right wholesome memes
right um mental health awareness
there's like simultaneously
nervous system regulation trauma
informed work
um you know
reef work grief work
all these and then there's like the
reclamation of like okay so now that
so how do we come out of the cave now in
this day and age
and embody what it means to be [ __ ]
animals playing on our big mama gaia
together in a way that's
very loving rather than accidentally
violent due to our in
ignorance that we are only harming
ourselves and how do we embody that
through embodying
the resonance of the celebration of the
joy of the
vibrational permission of showing the
possibility
of what is available without being
making the other team wrong
without making another team to
and so yeah that's the thing we were
talking about it's like the more
the more full of truth you are
the more joyful and playful you are
because you realize there's only this
moment that anything that's
ever trying to make anything happen is
not an efficient way to actually
experience the best possible outcome
in this reality right there's something
deeper that's already knows what it's
doing
that's playing through all of us and
then here we are
the more we play with it simultaneously
when we're really enjoying it and
playing with it
yeah it's just a paradox that unites the
paradoxes of like
relentless freedom and ease and
mercy and innocence and like the most
badass [ __ ] um full
embodied service but it's changing the
way we show up
to affect the world right rather than a
world we have to change
it's a world that's already inherently
perfect that we're here to play with
and let our love guide us beyond
the illusion of like oh i love this
person so much
that i have to change them
simultaneously somehow it's the love
which unifies the perceived
nuances of the different paradoxes of
the separations and it's like
how can i work with the process already
happening a
constant perfecting itself everything
and just let that happen through me so
yeah i'm just i'm just in
i'm just laughing right now to my inside
myself about the [ __ ] paradox of the
like relentless earnest seriousness
and the complete ridiculous cosmic joke
yeah giggle fest plus earnestness merged
into one
yep and it's so real what we're doing
right now
i just feel such a burning um
you know such a burning
[Music]
you know it's the passion you know i
feel the burning desire
for the world to know what is possible
now because i love my human family so
much
and i acknowledge that they are a part
of me
simultaneously how can i be the medicine
by embodying the unity consciousness
that has been forgotten in the illusion
of an external world that was really
only my
own creation to
to just [ __ ] celebrate
i like how you said in that last bit you
had
the kabbalah non-dual meditation as you
were growing up
is already like a huge a lot of
um teenagers
in modernity getting access to something
like that is mission critical in the
global enlightenment pedagogy
so you know just just a little
meditation on recognizing that
even right now
taking our slow inhalations and
exhalations
and this is why so many of the mystics
talked about
silence being key
slow everything down go all the way back
to patanjali
2 000 years ago go back to yoga [ __ ]
of riti niro the union with god with the
absolute is simply the cessation of the
fluctuations of
mind itself calm it down
and then use the breath and
feel into the actual uniting
on each inhalation and exhalation with
the absolute inescapable divinity
that you already are
and i adore that and to bring that to
teenagers is perfect and
i love that i love how you talked about
the al chemistry that's happening
the very metamorphosis that's why johann
wolfgang von guerta
said that light prismatically
refracting into the visible light
spectrum and the metamorphosis of the
caterpillar to the butterfly
those two phenomena are proof that the
ultimate educational lecture belongs in
the artist sphere of work
so light prismatically refracting the
visible light spectrum
and metamorphosis of caterpillar
butterfly are proof that the ultimate
educational lecture
lies in the artist's sphere of work that
in itself is motivation enough for us to
realize
that our nature is that process
endless you will never come to the end
of all of the different ways
that a caterpillar becomes a butterfly
and you will never come to the all of
the
end of the different ways that
we put musical notes into a song or that
we color a blank canvas
with art or that we put together images
into a movie or we combine food into a
recipe or we vibrate vocal cords to make
languages
or we modulate a screen yeah
with its create never come to the end
and so enjoy what eternity slash
infinity actually is and enjoy
that you are that yeah this
fireworking is the absolute and
just relax into the very nature of the
[ __ ] beautiful firework
itself it's the best thing you can do
for the planet i promise
you
[Music]
i feel very passionate about the
teenager thing obviously
i had an awakening as a teenager which
was
quite challenging but also the thing
that actually
kept me going i thought like a flaming
heart of purpose
was born in that suffering the seed of
purpose was buried in that
suffering in this i was so i was born
and raised in high school in
palo alto california in the silicon
valley
tech hub of the world
supposed to be the best public schools
the people there are wealthy and smart
social media just became a thing i got
to witness firsthand
what it does how it takes us makes us
even harder
of a process to realize what is actually
here in nature
it makes it a lot harder because we
confuse we get into even
uh anyway that's a whole another story
but
i got to witness the first hand effects
of that on my body
on my experience on my experience of
disconnection from the world around me i
felt completely disconnected from my
environment
had to turn inward because nowhere i
looked for outside
would give me a feeling of connection
or validation or feeling seen or
understood
or loved so i had to learn to meditate
basically and i'm so grateful
um but yeah it was
quite challenging and now we have social
media
so now we have the internet so now we
have thoughts spreading and spreading
and spreading
so now it's like figuring out a way to
make this be revealed as simple
and non-intimidating and like
because it changes everything and it's
so massive and yet it's so mundane
and it's not the enlightened group that
has it in the non-spiritual people don't
get it
it's a love that includes and makes it
safe
for everyone to feel um
somehow yeah to communicate the true
heart and the spirit of
whatever this is um
yeah to let children know they are loved
to let the teenagers know they are loved
that they are love that they should
shall
are loving creating the love and the
to be oneself is to be creative and and
and i'm so passionate about that so i'm
right there with you
because i forgot i didn't have people
around me to remind me i was loved
in high school and that [ __ ] me and
it's [ __ ] so many humans on this earth
you know and it's it was a beautiful
[ __ ]
luckily you know i was privileged and
and at the same time i've experienced
[Music]
i've experienced uh
how difficult it is to be raised in this
day and age with the onset of
you know social media technology
all the world crisis it's such an
important time more than ever
to really learn these practices and even
deeper than pure mindfulness
and yoga uh what is actually
the root of yoga what is actually the
root of meditation
like can we just go back for a second
and just honor for a second where these
teachings came from and what they were
pointing to
and yeah so i'm excited to be on this
journey of getting to make
this less intimidating for people
exactly
that's exactly it and that you mentioned
that as you were
going through as well i'll loop back to
that in a second
that you have these words
like yoga which means union in sanskrit
or mysticism which again means becoming
one
with the god or the absolute what are
you uniting with in yoga with god with
absolute
and so what have you forgotten you've
forgotten that you are already that and
so what are you doing you're just going
back through this veilus veil and
communing with your true
perfect divine fireworky fractally
nature
and to be yourself is to be the art that
you
are and then embodied
living your life and then
you mentioned this 3d to 4d in the
law of one and in many of the other
metaphysical maps
is a understanding that if you
look at the human as a evolutionary step
where is the human evolving toward well
the human is evolving toward
going away from the limbic primal
self-dealing
finite egoic condition psychology
identity form layers of onion
two what it's going toward
unlocking the heart chakra that fourth
the
green the love light unity
connecting point of this is all one
heart
many hands one heart manus multi cor
unum
and so under that process
e pluribus unum out of many one and
out of that process what do you get you
get
enlightenment you get awakening that is
what
the traditions point to is unlocking
that heart chakra
recognizing oneself as that firework of
infinity recognizing everyone as that
firework their
own unique artistic embodied firework of
infinity coming together
as an enlightened civilization to
maximize prosperity maximize
abundance maximize harmony well-being
all of those
good things and like you described there
are these architectures there are these
fundamental
aspects to getting people from that
yellow to the green from the 3d to 4d
and you listed some mental health
awareness stream entry
trauma shadow grief work mentorship
creating these little spiritual
trampolines and these landing zones all
this type of stuff
and it has to be it has to also have the
peace of
self-realization right
like you said the buddha and the atlas
have to be together
so there's been a interesting movement
around
um being wary of spiritual bypass and
dealing with like not using spiritual
ideas to
dissociate more deeply and separate
ourselves more deeply from our humanness
and that's the piece that i love that
you speak about it's like the inclusion
right the true nonduality
true unity includes everything
it includes the [ __ ] it doesn't raise
itself about the [ __ ] it roots into the
[ __ ] to grow the [ __ ] garden of
heaven on earth
um and embraces our whole humanity and
it is
all merciful love that embraces our
whole
humanity and really is here to humble us
i find
right it gets really it's really so the
infinite
the way that the pure nothing that is
everything has the most fun it's like
hmm so it's chilling right chilling pure
chill
pure beyonce
and then it's like okay how do i get
into the nittiest grittiest
crate the most like nonsensical
twisted illusions of separation
experienced in the body
and and exasperated by the suffering of
the mind stories about what is felt in
the body
held in place as a perceived reality by
the mind stories
on the original impressions felt within
the body
the impressions of discord
that is the greatest teacher of our true
nature which is beyond
all sensation right and then
the greatest thing for that thing to do
right it realizes
oh i am beyond all this and at the same
time it knows this that's why it came
here to forget
so we can't negate the suffering it has
to be an inclusion
of of the whole human experience
and it has to be that everywhere we are
i'm already that i don't have to get
anywhere
right it's okay to be content
and that's the greatest and i just love
continuing to hammer it in that the more
we allow ourselves to be content
and be truly free the more efficient
we can simultaneously be in helping more
of the world become content
because we are embodying creating that
we are embodying that
state of the creator knowing ourselves
as a creator as creation
knowing there's nothing to to to grasp
that will make us content ever
on a superficial level therefore it's
the inherent
satisfaction of being the creator
creating knowing there's nothing to hold
but everything to keep giving
so there's no trying to stifle it by
trying to
have it all and it's the greatest
satisfaction for the infinite to do
is to find itself in the places that
most forgot
that they are that and to get into the
little juicy details
and so now this is the part where we're
getting into the juicy details of like
the body and like the stories and like
and how it's playing out on the human
the
co-created human masterpiece art project
of like all the beautiful
flowering expressions of different
indigenous cultures
and modern political
spheres and technological advancements
and somatic understanding and
creative blossoming it just gets to be
really exciting because we get to
infuse into and uncover contin
continuously uncover the unknown we're
pioneering the unknown we're like
it's like it's like okay if maybe once
upon a time we were like hey
chilling at infinity wee let's go into
the perception of the universe
and then as and then as souls we do that
into the earth
and now we're doing that as a collective
again
into the next frontier right the next
dimension if you will
the next stage of evolution if you will
um our destiny for embodiment universal
realization of what's
already here beyond the perception of
time which when we open up to
um moves
moves yeah i love i love you bringing it
back to the slowing down
because it's like the paradox that the
more we slow down
the more we connect to godspeed
more godspeed through us
the more we tap into the place from
which
creation comes and then we're not
wrestling with
what is or creating the new that's
already being created through us
rather than distracting ourselves
thinking we're creating something new
but we're actually not embodying the
place of creator realization
from which creation is already naturally
happening through all of us as
one creator and uh
so yeah i'm excited to create like oh
wow what happens when we create and we
all realize we're creating together
actually not only are we all creating
together on this planet
we all created together this experience
we are the earth we are the sun
yeah the universe we are the creator we
are the water
we are the air we are we are the trees
so i'm just excited for the chapter in
the human evolution game
and i'm like yeah and i'm
humbled by the amount of love that's
calling me into and amount of [ __ ]
that it's bringing up
in me and the amount of mercy that there
is in permission here
within this beautiful earth in the
paradox of it all to just [ __ ] live
my life
and enjoy being everyone together
yes so
i would take everything that was just
said there
and i would basically call that post
realization like you have to get
up to the place where
you go beyond coming and going
where you go beyond creation and
destruction where you go beyond
everything and nothingness where you go
beyond
birth and death beyond that
beyond that to just the ineffable
perfection that that is
and then you realize that
truly and then only then
can you really understand
what's happening in terms of the
creation
that we're going through
and then you can be your unique firework
but until the point that you realize
that
you are the absolute
beyond-ness period
and then then then you can come into
your cool little
firework and the entire creation
experience that we're going through of
the
mud and the lotus flower which is cool
but but to to know that first
and then get to what we've been talking
about post realization
is really important you are that which
never comes and goes
yeah you are that which never opens and
closes
you know this it's there's just one the
heart and that is
this this
is that so
you know period just sink in relax
in as was said a moment ago just slow
down
stop the fluctuations of mind
to the point of where
you talk slower to the point
of where there's more
pause between the words
so that each word that
is delivered can be
of greater god love light
perfection when you talk too fast it is
harder for
it to be a precise word of god's love
life because you are talking too fast
because you feel like there's something
to do
or something to say or something to
prove or there's some lack or some need
it is harder to find
the right precise god's love light
word when you're talking faster so slow
yourself down
to the point where you really become
aware of the profundity
of observation itself
of witnessing itself of awareness
itself recognize
just like in your dream at night when
you
simulate out awareness and the reality
this is that this
is that you've simulated out
awareness you've simulated out
a reality for leela
for the divine play endlessly
you will be doing this but you are
beyond doing this
enjoy
enjoy
that's a good wrap perfect perfect
beautiful first of many of these that
was i love that tennis
the tennis between the adama and atlas
costume
the i am really enjoyed it yeah
i love we got to so many good things
there was giggle fest plus earnestness
i love that one
[Music]
i still feel the touchiness of the
giggles
because uh we have to be so
serious about what's happening in the
world
which is why it's very important that we
giggle so we can really address it
seriously
rather than have some shows on this
thing we're doing when we're actually
disconnected from our authentic thing
that's wanting to actually earnestly
happen
right
so authenticity is a nice word
also where can people find
you to follow online and whatnot we'll
put the link in the bio below what's the
best place to
follow you yeah my instagram is
at source scribe and
such a good instagram great i'll add
that in the bio and my website
which i yeah i haven't like fully
launched but it's
should be good enough to go is www
dot adi on e a d i
o n a i dot com
hell yeah so pumping for i have youtube
too so
find me there and we'll put that link in
the below so we have
website instagram youtube also i think
that we will be a
good collaborative partner with
one another on helping
uh adama's youtube channel
prosper because he's looking to
interview more awakened
and enlightened beings and share their
experiences
and awaken more people around the planet
create the butterfly effect and so
let's let's feel free to send him dms of
you know of recommendations and of uh by
the way this platform is really good for
you this is called stream yard it's so
simple
just like what we did literally just
sending out a little invite link
right and then all you do is you just
switch to this view
and then you select the channels you
want to broadcast to
right and it's so simple and easy and so
yeah
yeah so okay
actually for you go ahead because you
were doing a little interview show right
you had simulation
or you have simulation you are doing an
interview thing
but it it came from i didn't get too
into it because i've always been more
into like
what's deeper than the mind what's
coming through me but then you have
people that are like doing really cool
things with the mind
creativity stuff on the earth in your in
your old
simulation thing and now you're like
i've just been loving seeing this like
oh cool
here he goes into this thing great
where are you at with how it was before
and what it is now
what's your what's the objectives of
simulation right now because there's
been a bit of a
shift of prioritization of topics it
sounds like
yeah it's just the caterpillar turning
into the butterfly
that's all that's all it is right the
four years of what this
has been has turned from you know
i'm gonna interview you know a person a
day because i want to know my true
nature i need to know what's going on in
science and spirituality and the nature
of reality and consciousness i need to
know
and now it's dude i figured it out
it was around my neck the whole [ __ ]
time
and so now it's like
i'm excited to merge the worlds
i'm excited to see you do that and to be
a part of that to see what happens all
around us with that
that that's the anchoring terrestrially
of the realizations that's what's meant
by tantra
that's the atlas portion of buddha plus
atlas
it's the buddha with his consort yeah
right
the eternal cosmic love making masculine
and feminine
awareness and uh yeah
we're so grateful for this episode and
we're also very grateful for
our our audience we would love we would
love to hear
from you in the comments below on how
you feel about the episode let us know
what you think also like the video
it helps the algorithm also subscribe if
you haven't also share the video with
people that you feel like this would
resonate with
and i would actually love it if you guys
loved the video i personally
i would love it if you loved it yeah
yeah yeah and
also check out the links in the bio
again go and give adam a follow on
instagram and also
on youtube and check out his website
soon as well
over there and that's all i'll go ahead
and end
the broadcast and we can stay in the
studio and chat a little bit
okay thank you thanks everyone
yay
giggle [ __ ] plus earnestness yeah